[Music]
[Applause]
Jim Jackson said to join us sir on loan
NBA on TNT Clippers analyst he does it
all he was on the call game two Warriors
and the Kings he's on the call for the
Lakers Grizzlies tonight he's a busy man
and rightfully so he's done a great job
uh Jim thanks for joining us your
reaction in the moment
with what happened with Draymond and now
your reaction after the commissioner
decided to suspend him
well we saw the play right there I saw
what sabonis did which
you know shouldn't have happened but in
the midst of a lot of things things go
on so both were in the wrong in that
perspective it's a bonus of the never
grabbed Draymond Draymond should have
never stomped down his reaction to what
happened because it was a physical game
up to that point you know what I'm
saying Dan so both teams were competing
um I I kind of knew at the time that it
was either going to be a flagrant one or
flagrant too just because of the
excessiveness in which Draymond came
down with his foot
right wrong or indifferent that's what
happened now I didn't think he was going
to be suspended okay I just knew
fragrant two done for the game play on
he comes back but as you know and as we
know there's a track record there and
they said it in a statement in regards
to having some other forms of
unsportsman like conduct so that I think
the Commissioner's Office uh took that
into consideration I am surprised by it
um that it went that far but um it's an
unfortunate situation for
Golden State but I think for the series
itself in regards to Draymond not being
able to play but again it goes back to
Draymond making a decision at that point
too or what he wanted to do but Jim he's
supposed to frustrate the opposition
he's not supposed to be frustrated and
and that I think if there's the stomp
now he went back for a second helping
that hurt him and if he would have been
a little bit more contrite after the
game which he's not capable of doing but
just said and and not done all the WWE
stuff
I I think he could have he could have
gotten by with a fine here but the
Commissioners in the audience and you're
watching him kind of take over Center
Stage nobody why doesn't anybody from
Golden State grab him because they can't
because they don't have anybody they
don't they don't have anybody I think
when a David West was there it was yeah
okay with David West okay I think and to
your point too
the escalation with the fans
added incentive for what I think the
decision ultimately came down to because
you think about it Adam Silver sitting
in the stand
so he's hearing the backdrop of the fans
of what they're saying too in regards to
kicking him out he shouldn't be playing
dirty play all this other stuff so all
this stuff is going through his mind and
I can't think for the commissioner but
based on the statement they took all of
this into consideration it wasn't just
to stop
it was a stump it was the fan
interaction it was probably Draymond not
being contrite afterwards and it was his
past does it make it right or wrong I
don't know but as a decision that
Draymond
allowed the commissioner's office to
make he put that in their control and
took it out of his control at the end of
the day
forget what happened right wrong or
indifferent
with sabonis and and grabbing the leg at
the end of the day you still can make a
decision on what you choose to do and
how you choose to handle it now if you
want to handle it in the way you want to
okay fine you want to stop them fine
then their repercussions to that
and you got to understand once you have
repercussions
that now the decision making of what
happens next is out of your control
because of your past if that's
come on Looney probably doesn't happen
it doesn't go down like that but it's
Draymond Green
different scenario let's look at the
series though itself because I thought
that lost in the headline was Sacramento
showed composure it was a tight game and
they won the game they're supposed to
win those games Golden State once again
is going to have to win a game in
Sacramento if if they're going to
advance so let's handicap this series
now with five games left
I think golden said get two at home I
don't think they played their best
basketball but they haven't played their
best basketball on the road all year
yeah now you can't take anything away
from the level of maturity that the
Kings displayed I think that's what
you're talking about see Mike Brown has
done a fantastic job of a couple dates I
mean this team
they streamline their roster what do I
mean by that is that they had a lot of
overlapping positions before where guys
didn't really understand what their role
was because they had a bunch of forwards
playing and guys trying to jockey
position and was just it you really
didn't have continuity when they made
the trade with Halliburton and they
loved Halliburton
but they knew that he couldn't play
alongside of Darren foxes both needed
the basketball
so that was the first step into what we
see Sacramento being today and Mike
Brown
he's grown as a coach since his Laker
day since his Cleveland Cavalier today
we always talk about players maturing
Mike Brown said listen
back when I was younger I used to worry
about X's and O's practice times and and
getting plays right and all of these
things on the court he said as he
learned and matured as a coach when he's
at Golden State he understood that it
was okay how do I connect with my
players on and off the court how do we
develop camaraderie off the court how
are they with their family and their
family life all these other things that
brought this team together so now
you can coach your best player Darren
Fox extremely hard without any pushback
because they understand that you care
about them more as a person than as a
player so that's the Sacramento side the
golden taste side here's the issue Dan
they turn the ball over too much yeah
okay and you can say what they've always
done it yeah but their margin of error
was bigger than because they can get
defensive stops there's ways that they
could play the offset turning the
basketball over a lot and still win game
they're margin of error right now is a
lot smaller they're not the same
defensive team they're not as deep in
regards to what once they once were so
now those turnovers that happened early
in the game or mid third quarter they
come back to cost in particular on the
road so that's the issue that's that's
the challenge I see with golden state
especially trying to win one in
Sacramento against a feisty hungry
determined and quite mature young
Sacramento team talking to Jim Jackson
he'll be on the call tonight it's the
Lakers Grizzlies game two what's the
availability of John marant
we're still waiting to see you know it's
unfortunate because it was the hand that
he had hurt it was taken before and you
saw it came down kind of it bit back
um so we're still trying to wait to see
what's going on with that so it'll
probably be a game time decision I would
think of something close to it later in
the day
it's weird to be on a bandwagon of a
team that nearly lost the play-in game
but I like what I'm seeing with the
Lakers
uh should I be liking what I'm seeing
with the Lakers big picture could they
be the best team in the Western
Conference it could be I mean our
Clippers you know Paul George comes back
and I'm biased from that perspective in
regards to their depth and what they
have
they could be pretty formidable and you
know going into the playoffs too I
thought that the teams with the higher
seeds four five and six
were probably better
than or as competitive as the top three
seeds Denver Sacramento and Memphis
unlike the East you know it's kind of a
separation now outside of Giannis being
hurt with you know Milwaukee
76ers and also Boston those three kind
of separated themselves
um
roblinga did a great job I'm an
outstanding job with the trades because
he got lent the defensive presence he
got some more shooting
um the the team is now able to compete
at a different level
um you have multiple ball handlers that
can make plays when LeBron is not in the
game which is what they were looking for
and A.D has been healthy enough to be
able to carry the load which as you know
is the most important key to anything
else so I I like where the Lakers
at mentally because they feel different
I was around the team um last night and
they feel a lot different than what they
did earlier in the year from a
confidence perspective I mean so it's
tangible it's something that they're
exuding that confidence
oh big time and you think about this too
and this is not taking anything away
from Memphis but I always thought that
even Memphis Memphis healthy with Steven
Adams and Brandon Clark
they still were growing from a
basketball maturity perspective and I
think that's very important to
understand a basketball maturity not
that they're not mature young men but a
basketball maturity to win it in a
playoff series against a Lakers team in
a seven game series against a LeBron
James and a Dennis Schroeder and a
Anthony Davis I don't know if they've
gotten to that point yet because you got
to be able to be focus in on the little
things that count the little intricate
detail not let the outside forces take
you away and I'm not sure that Memphis
is there yet they have a lot of bravado
and I love the youth in this the the
youthfulness that they have but you're
playing against a more mature Lakers
team with guys that have been there and
done that and I thought that favored the
Lakers going into this year
I I'm surprised sometimes when players
get in LeBron's face they challenge
LeBron they say things to LeBron
and they nobody ever did that to Michael
Jordan
yeah he did
no oh yeah oh yeah what the Pistons oh
man Mike and I got into it no I'm not
and I'm not saying that I'm Kobe Bryant
or somebody else but I wasn't gonna let
Mike just walk all over me okay you know
what I mean at all we got into it we got
to enjoyed a lot I got into it with Kobe
I mean a lot of players do it now the
result of that may be something totally
different
at the end of the day but as players
okay so you get in Jordan's face because
Memphis is not afraid of LeBron
between being very competitive and want
to compete and having disrespect yes two
different things it feels like
disrespect to LeBron
It Well by some of the Grizzlies from
well it was really Dylan yeah that's
that that's disrespect but I don't think
people disrespected Mike
you did I think Isaiah did
well he does now exactly he didn't care
then
but did he say it in a way that oh yeah
oh yeah
yeah back then and you know it was
little innuendos in the press
conferences and things they said about
Jordan okay you know in regards to them
not Jordan not being able to beat them
finally they did okay on you know but oh
yeah I mean they talked about birds
think about this think about who was it
that's Isaiah remember the quote he said
about bird about if he wasn't a white
guy
yeah
if he was a black guy it'd be just
another Ford but that was exactly I was
there for that Rodman and Isaiah
both said that in that sounded
disrespect yes it did okay and then we
saw the end we saw we saw the end result
and some guys he just he just ain't dead
sometimes you just want to leave alone
you know what I mean and and Larry Bird
was one of them Michael Jordan but
that's a competitive nature
to me with guys I just don't like I
don't I don't mind a guy going out and
talking junk I don't mind that but don't
just don't be disrespectful because
LeBron James I don't think you have to
bow down to him I think you have to
compete I think he respects that when
the the greatest players respect when
guys come out because that pushes them
to another level but but if you're going
to be disrespectful then there's some
things that come along with that too and
more importantly Dan
got to be able to back it up
you got to be able to back it up you're
gonna talk all of this the whole time
and can back it up
you know it's just it's just wasted
breath but you can see the light going
on probably if you do it to Kobe or Mike
like you know that you know what you've
done you've tugged on Superman's cape
and now is when you're saying I gotta
hold up my end of the bargain here
because I know got to I know they're
coming at me well and it's a lot easier
to to talk to a 38 year old LeBron who's
not the same kind of player okay it's
like talking to talking junk to Mike
when he was in with the Wizards now he
can still go off and give you 40. 50 but
it's not the same as it was a young mic
in Chicago when he could just had the
full-born energy to go out and just beat
you not only offensively but more
important defense if we really get up
into you and change the game as well so
it's a lot easier to to talk a little
bit more smack to a 38 year old LeBron
than it was when he was what was he when
he dropped on um Detroit when he was in
Cleveland the first time when he had
like 25 in the fourth quarter and was
going off or what he did to Boston when
he was in Miami that's a whole different
animal
uh do you think Jordan would have load
managed if he was playing now
it's hard I don't but the personality
type thing with Kobe low manage I would
say I can't imagine
I can't admit well I say because
Gianna's low managed no it's Dame
Lillard loan manage no the staff load
managed no those guys even though
they're brought up in this era they're
built a little bit different they think
a little bit different
you know what I mean Kobe and Jordan it
was about the game now their
perspectives would have been different
because they grew up in this airplane a
different way I don't think Michael
Jordan would be the same Michael Jordan
we saw in the mid 90s
why is that because Michael Jordan loved
to get on that right block or that left
block and post up you don't see a lot of
that so Michael Jordan growing up as a
young youth playing basketball he
wouldn't have been posting up as much
because the game has changed around him
it would be more shooting on the
perimeter pick and roll stuff like that
not that he wouldn't be dynamic but I
just think mentally he would be a
different kind of player because of the
approach of how he grew up playing the
game
always great to visit with you have fun
tonight and uh thanks for joining us
um you know I just want to ask I mean I
I like pizza too you know what I mean I
I do like pizza no pork but I take the
pizza though you can have like a
margarita pizza and just
open invite to the man cave Channel
you want to come into my Dojo I got a
basketball hoop here
no I didn't get some golf clubs you
still got the putt I I got my uh my golf
simulator here there you go there we go
oh so no no basketball just golf no
basketball no this is gone
because I'd like to shoot against you
well we can do that we can replay low
horns
how about blindfolded free throws bet
all day long oh well you better make
eight out of ten
well I mean hey I was thinking nine or
ten what do you mean all right then then
you probably beat me maybe but I'm gonna
make eighty percent from the line
blindfolded okay
back
what did you shoot what was your career
you weren't a great free throw shooter
oh yes I was great guess what look it up
what were you one year 83 my later my
later years I was in the 90s okay
all right I had to change my game
brother
Paulie check check see if Jim's telling
me the truth there yeah I got uh at age
34 he shot 93 second in the league
career 83 83 I just told I said 83 for
your as a free throw yeah for you
at 34 years old what do you mean
I'll shoot it at 66 years of age
that's different shooting than your man
cage than being on the court I know that
in front of everybody
this is not the small gym after after
after Jordan has torched you for 40 and
then you go to the line you knock down a
couple of free throws hey I had a couple
of really good games
he had a lot more
uh have fun tonight thank you again
that's uh Jim Jackson NBA on TNT will be
on the call for the Lakers Grizzlies
back after this